aquí tenemos una traducción del problema
de razonamiento deductivo muy divertido
que ha estado circulando por el internet
en estos últimos días de hecho de hecho
varias personas me lo enviaron a mí por
redes sociales y pensé que sería algo
muy entretenido si pudiéramos hacer un
vídeo de este problema entonces este
problema dice alberto y bernardo se
hicieron amigos de cherry y quieren
saber cuándo es su cumpleaños serio les
da una lista de 10 fechas posibles muy
bien y aquí están estas 10 fechas ahora
dice cherry y le dice el mes de su
cumpleaños alberto y el día a bernardo
de forma separada
entonces para para tener muy claro qué
es lo que está pasando vamos a checar
esto el mes se lo dice a alberto
mientras que el día se lo dice
a bernardo y por supuesto aquí este
problema pues tenemos que suponer que
estos dos amigos son muy buenos lógicos
guardados son muy buenos
utilizando la lógica y además por
ejemplo alberto sabe que le dieron el
mes pero alberto debería saber que a
bernardo le dieron el día ok al mismo
tiempo bernardo pues sabe el día y
también debes saber que a alberto le
proporcionaron la información del mes
con esto yo creo que es información
suficiente para poder resolver el
problema ahora bien después viene una
conversación alberto dice yo no sé
cuándo es el cumpleaños del serviu pero
sé que bernardo tampoco lo sabe muy bien
eso es lo primero que dice alberto
después dice bernardo en principio no
sabía cuándo era el cumpleaños de cherry
pero ahora lo sé que y segunda
afirmación y la última afirmación dice
dice alberto entonces yo también sé
cuándo es el cumpleaños de cherry
esto es bastante interesante la pregunta
es cuándo es su cumpleaños por supuesto
el cumpleaños de cherry y como siempre
en muchos otros vídeos lo m lo hemos
hecho te invito a que hagas una pausa y
que trates de resolver este problema por
tu propia cuenta que de por sí es muy
divertido ahora bien si lo intentas por
tu cuenta te hago una sugerencia trata
de hacer un diagrama o algún esquema que
tenga toda la información desde el punto
de vista de alberto verdad y otro
diagrama que tenga la información desde
el punto de vista de bernardo quizás con
eso pueda resolver fácilmente el
problema muy bien y con con estos
enunciados pregúntate qué puedes ir
deduciendo de estas de estas
afirmaciones
entonces suponiendo que ya ya te tomaste
un tiempo para pensar este problema
vamos a ver cómo se resuelve y por
supuesto si en algún momento sientes que
ya estás inspirado como para resolver el
problema por tu propia cuenta da una
pausa e inténtalo muy bien entonces como
dijimos vamos a hacer algunos diagramas
que tengan la información de alberto y
de bernardo entonces primero hagamos el
diagrama para alberto ok entonces de
todas estas fechas tenemos los meses
mayo junio julio y agosto verdad
entonces por ejemplo si nosotros
fuéramos alberto y nos dijeran que el
cumpleaños de chevrel es en mayo y
quizás debería ponerlo más bien con
minúscula que tenemos que su cumpleaños
fuera en mayo tenemos tres opciones
tenemos el día 15 el 16 y el 19 ahora si
nos hubieran dicho que su cumpleaños es
en el mes de junio tenemos dos opciones
día 17 y día 18 verdad aquí tenemos
dos opciones si por el contrario nos
hubieran dicho que el cumpleaños es en
julio entonces tendríamos de opciones el
día 14 y el día 16 y finalmente si nos
hubieran dicho que fue lo que su
cumpleaños es en agosto tendríamos tres
oportunidades que fuera el día 14 el día
15 o el día 17 muy bien
este 7 ahora hagamos un esquí un esquema
para bernardo que tenemos a bernardo y a
bernardo solo tenemos algunas opciones
de días por ejemplo le pudieron haber
dicho yo creo que el más chico es el día
14 el día 14 y si le hubieran dicho que
fue el día 14 tiene de opción julio y
agosto nada más
muy bien tendría la opción de julio o
bien de agosto si le hubieran dicho el
día 15 el día 15 tenemos de opción mayo
o bien agosto ok
mayo
agosto
si le hubieran dicho por ejemplo que fue
el día 16 tendríamos de opciones mayo y
julio aunque entonces tenemos de
opciones mayo y julio si le hubieran
dicho que fue el día 17 tendremos de
opciones junio y agosto
y agosto también pudieron haberle dicho
el día 18 y este es este es un punto
interesante en este problema si lo
hubieran dicho el día 18 sólo tendríamos
una opción que sería junio verdad o bien
si le hubieran dicho el día 19 sólo
tenemos una opción el día 19 es solo
tenemos la opción de mayo ahora porque
esto es interesante bueno es es que si
le hubieran dicho el día 18 o el día 19
entonces él inmediatamente sabría en qué
mes nació cherry ok y entonces sabría
cuál es la fecha de su cumpleaños
ahora bien vamos a ir leyendo los
enunciados y vamos a ver si podemos ir
resolviendo este problema entonces
primero alberto dice yo no sé cuándo es
el cumpleaños de cherry y eso tiene
sentido verdad porque si a él le dan
cualquiera de estos meses pues tiene
varias opciones lo cual tiene sentido
que no no sepa cuándo es su cumpleaños
pero además dice pero yo sé que bernardo
poco lo sabe muy bien entonces quiere
decir que no le pudieron haber dicho a
bernardo el día 18 o el día 19 verdad
justamente por lo que dijimos si le
hubieran dicho 1819 sólo tienen una
opción ya sea junio o mayo y entonces
bernardo sabría en qué mes en qué día es
el cumpleaños de cherry entonces esto de
aquí simplemente lo podemos traducir
como que bernardo bernardo no obtuvo no
obtuvo 18 o 19
ahí lo tienen ahora pensemos un momento
más como alberto cómo sabría alberto que
bernardo no obtuvo ni el 18 y el 19
bueno
como alberto solo le dan los meses
quiere decir que alberto no le pudieron
haber dado ni junio ni mayo verdad es la
única forma de decir que sabe que
bernardo no obtuvo ni el 18 y el 19
entonces podemos ir tapando y quitando
junio y quitando mayo verdad esos son
los meses que pueden recibir alberto
como sabe que bernardo no pudo haber
recibido ni el 18 y el 19 quiere decir
que no pudo haber obtenido ni mayo ni
junio muy bien entonces podemos
quitarlos de ambos diagramas verdad
ahora veamos que es lo que dice bernardo
vamos a tomar otro color dice bernardo
en principio no sabía cuando era el
cumpleaños de cherry y eso ya lo vimos
verdad porque no es ni junio de hecho de
hecho todavía deberíamos quitar más
información verdad aquí hay junio mayos
mayos ya quitamos esta información esta
no era posible entonces bernardo dice en
principio no sabía cuándo era el
cumpleaños de cherry aunque quiere decir
que no le dio ni el 18 y el 19 pero
ahora sí sabe cuándo es su cumpleaños
quiere decir que por ejemplo si le
dieron el número 17 pues inmediatamente
sabe que es agosto porque la opción de
junio ya no es más bien ya no es una
opción verdad si le hubieran dicho que
el 16 pues inmediatamente sabría que es
julio y si le hubieran dicho el 15
quiere decir que le sabría
inmediatamente que es agosto entonces
pensemos ahora como bernardo si ya sabe
cuándo es el cumpleaños de cheryl quiere
decir que a él
no le dieron el día 14 verdad porque si
le hubieran dado el día 14 él no podría
saber si fue en julio o en agosto verdad
y de hecho si sabe ya cuando es su
cumpleaños entonces esta opción más bien
ya no es opción verdad y entonces eso
mismo podemos tachar lo del diagrama que
tenemos para alberto verdad lo
importante aquí es que bernardo decía
que ahora si sabe cuándo es su
cumpleaños entonces ya bien puede que le
hayan dicho 15 16 o 17 pero con el 14 no
puede deducir lo así que quitamos el 14
también de las opciones de alberto que
ahora por cierto dice que también sabe
cuándo es el cumpleaños de cheryl verdad
entonces por ejemplo si le dicen el mes
julio puede concluir inmediatamente que
el cumpleaños es el 16 sin embargo si le
dice en agosto entonces no podría
decidir si es el día 15 o el día 17
verdad así que tampoco agosto puede ser
una opción y por lo tanto alberto sabe
que el cumpleaños es en julio verdad de
hecho el cumple
es el 16 de julio así que cherry el
primero alberto le dijo el mes que era
julio mientras que a bernardo le dijo el
día 16 y con esto hemos resuelto el
problema que al menos a mí me se me hizo
muy divertido